[Music]
here's one of your superpowers as listed
from
mr jim
creating and sustaining a wonderful
intimate partnership with matt her
husband and lover since they were
teenagers have her talk about the risks
she and they were willing to take to
keep the relationship alive and vital
growing and intimate
if you are game to talk about that i
would be very
interested
yeah
to hear more
well
it's a challenge it's it's both a great
gift to be with a partner
since you were young you get to grow up
together there's a lot of a lot of
shared memories and shared friends and
there's a sweetness that it started out
with you get to keep and there's also a
great challenge of
the fact that we are different people
who evolve and change and so uh several
times at least three key times in our
relationship we've been willing to let
it all go
and
we've basically killed it off just said
the relationship as it was is done
now let's just check and see
is there a relationship what is the
relationship that wants to happen moving
forward
maybe it's just friends
co-parents maybe it's lovers
staying married what is it and so
we have a lot of courage both of us to
be willing to let go of what's not
working and trust
that
the right form of the relationship will
reveal itself and it just so happens
that it continues to be us married and
i think you know we play around often
sometimes we'll get up in the morning
i'll say something like uh hey you want
to be married today
and he'll say
oh well you know like what would that
mean what kind of a husband do i need to
be and we'll giggle and play around with
well you know how about this and this
and then
and then we choose and that is for me we
are
always choosing over and over again and
we always are willing to
to kind of to the point of um using the
work with byron katie of
i'm willing to open to the possibility
that not being married is just as okay
as being married
and what that has created is an
incredibly
vital
creative ever evolving passionate
marriage
in which we're freed up to
keep exploring new ways of of being
together and
i am really proud of my relationship i
think it's one of the greatest things
i've ever done
is the marriage that i have i we get a
lot of feedback that
it's an inspiring marriage to a lot of
people who
look to it and i do think it comes with
the courage to say no
you mentioned if at least i think you
said three times
that you've had this type of
conversation
i would like to zoom in on the first
conversation
were you both already
prepared and trained to initiate that
type of conversation did one side
initiate
the hey let's decide if we want to
remain as is or if we want to
take one of these other forms i'm just
wondering for people who are listening
who have never had one of these
conversations maybe they've been at the
breaking point but they've never had
this conversation
i initiated it
i initiated it it wasn't matt's
idea i said hey i'm
this isn't working for me the way we're
in relationship and there's a different
kind of a man i want to be with
than
than uh
than how you are
and i want something i want to i want
another possibility and so
i was i didn't know how to do all this i
was just toddling around trying to
figure this out
and um
i yeah i said i i don't want to do it
this way anymore and so
i thought that might mean that we needed
to be separated and that we needed to
end the marriage
and i was willing to we actually
got some support from
counselors about telling our kids that
we were going to divorce
because that's the only direction it
seemed like
we were gonna go
and then i had this great advice from a
friend who said okay diana you know i i
love you both if you think divorce is
what needs to happen that's great and
but i hear you complaining that
there's a certain man you want him to be
that he's not
and she said who is the woman you would
need to be to call forward that man
and my stomach dropped and i thought
i don't wanna i don't know about that
what and uh i realized oh i would need
to be a different woman
so
we said let's kill off this old marriage
and let's see if we can create a new one
and i'm going to keep asking myself who
do i need to be to call forward the man
i want to be with
and
about six months later
i was with the man i wanted to be with
and i remember saying to him you really
changed and he said no you really
changed and and the truth is we both
really changed but i was really grateful
for that first conversation of getting
being willing to let it go and then
getting the feedback of hey if you're
the creator
of of who's showing up over there who do
you need to be and
for
many months i felt like i was going to
throw up 24 7 learning to be a much more
vulnerable
needy
woman
who called forward the man who
you know could protect and and lead in a
way that i hadn't been willing to be in
the past
how did you thank you for sharing all
this by the way
and very courageous and vulnerable and
how did you figure out
who
you needed to be who who that woman was
to call forth the version
of your husband or the man who you
wanted to be with did you have help
did it was it obvious once you sat with
it
in terms of the changes that needed to
be made on your side or the things you
needed to cultivate or drop how did you
arrive at the answers at first i didn't
know i just knew i was really scared
when i asked the question
and so i i knew that my fear
uh you know i i believe that fear
is
when we're present is
an intelligence that says something
needs to get learned
something needs to get learned so when i
had that fear i thought oh wow something
needs to get learned there's i don't
know something here
and so
that was my first clue that her question
was powerful is the fear that arose in
me and then i just kept asking the fear
what needs to be learned i just kept
being really broad in that curiosity
i got into a state of wonder i wonder
who i would need to be to call forward
the man i most want to be with
i just kept asking that i wonder and i
let it be okay that i didn't have to
know because i didn't know i've been you
know with him for a long time and i
didn't know so i had to
be willing to listen and learn from
something
greater than my own
my own experience so far
and so it was in that level of curiosity
that i just
found my way
and it was just baby steps you know a
little bit here a little bit there and
that's happened actually several
different we've had several versions of
that often or not often but the three
versions were all some version of me
something needs to get learned for the
next evolution here
of this relationship
you